PayPal is facing backlash after shutting
down accounts belonging to conservative
websites this after two left-leaning
organizations labeled them as hate
groups one of those so-called hate
groups is jihad Watch which advocates
against radical Islam the accounts have
since been restored by PayPal but why
are companies getting so political in
the first place right now is the
director of jihad watch Robert Spencer
from Boston Robert good morning to you
good morning
okay what is jihad watch jihad watch is
dedicated to bringing news and
commentary about jihad activity violent
and stealthy in the United States and
around the world in all its forms and to
helping people to understand what is the
motivating ideology behind jihad
terrorism okay so really you're about
highlighting terrorism and yet this
group that a single you out said you had
extreme hostility toward Muslims is that
true yeah well there's no foundation to
that whatsoever we support any Muslim
who is interested in honestly
confronting the elements of Islam that
are used by jihadis
to justify violence and terrorism and
working toward reform okay so you are a
public awareness group essentially
trying to tell people about this
particular form of jihad what is going
on with the instance PayPal why did they
single you out what's going on with
Silicon Valley and right-leaning groups
well it's often often been noted that
the Southern Poverty Law Center has this
hate group list that contains many
legitimate groups and is trying to
defame those groups by lumping them in
with groups like the Ku Klux Klan and
the neo-nazis and jihad watch is one of
them along with many other important
organizations whose only real wrongdoing
is dissenting from the Southern Poverty
Law Center's hard left line but
Charlottesville is being used by the
left as its Reichstag fire moment its
opportunity to shut down all dissent and
so a leftist journalist Lauren Kirchner
from ProPublica wrote a piece about how
jihad watch uses PayPal to exceed
receive donations and other platforms
and within hours of the appearance of
this
and ProPublica we were shut down by
PayPal all right well you have since
been restored so you can get donations
that way going forward Robert Spencer
thank you very much for joining us today
from Boston to tell us what's going on
thank you
you bet so what do you think about that
email is friends at foxnews.com
meanwhile President Trump putting
pressure on Majority Li